[Music]
hey what's up everyone welcome back to
culturebench the wisecrack podcast where
we explore all the going on
goings-on going ons goings-on
going-ons of the contemporary cultural
zeitgeist
i'm michael constantly learning new
words joined by wisecrack's chief
financial analyst alec
and wisecrack's head of body double
recruiting
serbia that'll make more sense later how
are you all doing today
well how are you i'm great
wow good energy all around subdued
energy but a positive energy i would say
um so we have lots to talk about today
um we're going to get into the
the finance story that everyone's
talking about even those of us who
don't have stocks or stonks or know what
they are
we'll talk a little bit about you know
what it means to have another person to
do things for you that looks exactly
like you
and i'm going to talk a little bit about
corniness so to get started
um let's jump in to our slaps and our
chaps
as everyone knows if this is your first
time back in 2021 we've brought this
back we've decided that we do need a
little bit of negativity so we're doing
chaps as well
um serbia would you like to get us
started today
yes so i don't have
too many interesting chaps this week but
my slap is that i bought a
second hand like new herman miller chair
at a fairly low price
um my last chair broke probably because
i gained so much weight here during the
pandemic
and i'm really excited about this new
sturdier looking chair
these are herman miller chair that like
iconic office chair
yes these are things anyone who's under
30 as soon as you hit 30 you'll be very
excited about any news about
your chairs yeah i told some people at
work and they were all like
ah how did you get a herman miller
for 400. and i'm like
i know wow i had one of those at an old
job and i really wanted to steal it and
now that i look back i think i could
have
and one of my biggest regrets is not
stealing more from that job
well that's great and i think it's gonna
be great for your posture great for your
life
great for your interior design
sensibility thanks
okay so that's a really good thing yeah
do you have a chap
uh basically everything is just a long
running chap i feel like i'm a little
bit on a losing streak in both my
personal life and my professional life
so things are looking great obviously
i'm hoping the hermann miller chair i
bought yesterday is a turn
in the universe it sets things right
yeah it's [ __ ] you're you're in good
company serbia i'm sure like myself and
many of our listeners we're all
constantly failing in our professional
and personal life so we're all in this
together
um i don't trust you if things are going
well alec how about you
what are your slaps and chats this time
around you know i think what slaps
is hedge funds uh i really like them and
what chaps
is that uh when people take their hard
earned money away from them using
the same financial instruments that they
made they're well earned money for in
the first place so that's
that's going on guys it's being
sarcastic uh i mean
i'm looking at the dislike ratio but uh
i don't actually don't have a chaps but
i will say nothing has been more
i think something's wrong with me if
people i love when there's like a weird
like arcane or as9 thing that's
complicated
that i understand and someone asked me
to explain it and so just like multiple
friends coming out of the woodwork hey
alec do you understand what a short
squeeze is like i don't understand how
all this is working
and it just made me so happy to
literally describe the same thing like
18 times to my various friends
something's wrong with my brain it's not
a good thing sorry
i don't think i've ever been so full of
[ __ ] as i have had this past week with
multiple people in my life asking me to
explain that and me
doing my best effort but not being at
all confident yeah
um i i truly know almost nothing about
financial markets
other than i've enjoyed the film the big
short but i think i get this one but
you're gonna help me
understand if i get it and then a couple
minutes
um and then wait you said no so you that
was your whole bit
you're not really doing real slaps and
chaps that's fine i did a real slaps i'm
protesting chaps everything chaps
everything that's fine i forgot you're
allowed to protest chaps okay
i'll do mine real quick my slap is have
you all heard of this show that's called
house hunters comedians on the couch no
i know how i know householders yes as a
television program my partner discovered
last night
uh using a trial of the new discovery
plus
streaming service because we needed
another one although i think it does
have a bunch of guy fieri stuff on there
but there's a show in which comedians
watch an episode of house hunters and
roast it and it's like
real people like we watched the john
mulaney episode uh seth rogen is on one
of them and it was
a truly bizarre experience to watch very
famous and funny comedians just
roast someone looking for a
three-bedroom house for 560 or less in
the washington dc metropolitan area
i would just i recommend it it was a fun
thing to watch and i think
like many of us the the content wheel
can feel like it's getting a little bit
squeaky after so many months of being
inside watching things all the time so
i really enjoyed that my chap i guess is
also kind of tv related
um the some of you might remember a few
months ago i was very excited about the
nba bubble
and i was making a big stink of the fact
that i thought the national basketball
association was doing the best job of
any entertainment
league or sports league of managing the
pandemic and now all of that is
is gone they're playing regular games in
regular stadiums and now they're
allowing fans in including fans who are
sitting courtside including fans
sitting courtside with no masks on um
it's truly bizarre and there was a game
the other night if anyone hasn't seen
this you can just like look up the
phrase
courtside karen um but a a woman at an
elena hawks game decided she needed to
take her mask off and start screaming at
lebron james
uh feet away from him uh on the court
and it made me very upset
and it's very annoying that this
organization has shown that they know
the good stuff to do
and they're just not doing any of it so
that that's that's
that's a chapter for me yeah
there you go um cool so let's get into
it alec has already kind of teased this
everyone knows about the gamestop fiasco
i guess we could call it a fiasco it's
been going on for the past week
many of us myself included i've
struggled to really wrap our heads
around this one
um alec has done all the work for us
he's understood it
inside and out he's going to lay it all
out for us
what is a game stunk i i know i've
well first of all what level of
understanding do both of you have
don't know where to start you know don't
want to exclude everyone but also don't
want to rehash details that everyone
knows
i think we should be inclusive of our
audience and just start at the beginning
okay so fairness i think our audience
are geniuses but let's
just stomach yeah they're doing diamond
hands rocket ship emoji so i think they
they know what's going on but anyway
to make a long story short um hedge
funds
were including one melvin capital were
betting that the price of gamestop
stock would go down because it's a brick
and mortar store it's a shitty company
everyone hates them
uh somebody on a subreddit called wall
street bets
realized this and started being like hey
i think you know we could really
you know [ __ ] these people anyway uh
thousands tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands don't know the exact numbers
of people just started buying
gamestop stock to drive the price up
which led to a thing called a short
squeeze which
there's lots of great videos if you
don't know what it is we're gonna also
we have a video coming on this we'll
explain what that is
but it basically is a way to to hack the
system to keep the price going
up and up and up also thing called a
gamma squeeze which i don't
i'm not going to pretend to understand i
i'm not going to pretend to understand
it i read about and i couldn't i
couldn't tell you
um anyway the interesting thing that i
i i want to talk about is well there's a
there's a few things part of this is
that
um there's a popular trading app called
robinhood uh stopped
people from being able to buy gamestop
stock as well as other stocks that they
were doing this to like amc and amd
and blackberry and all these other ones
um there's also a component of the sec
said they're going to look into if there
is illegal market manipulation going on
and there's also just like this very
interesting socio-political
angle um we got an email from someone
named alberto who just said i'd love to
hear your opinions on this matter
personally i can't help but root for the
underdog
and find it equally hilarious and
alarming that a large enough group of
[ __ ] posters could wreak havoc on the
stock market no less
has the global pandemic desensitized me
in a way that i can
only laugh at ongoing crises is reddit
going to dictate what to invest in from
now on
is everything a meme now now let me say
there's been a lot of good memes
uh joy can you put up one of my
favorites elon musk
early on tweeted in support of game
stocks as it's called
which led to some epic things maybe
okay maybe we forgot to have it but
anyway it's order
we'll post a link in the description i'm
sorry everyone uh
but yeah it's fine what do you what are
what are all
takeaways on this
i'm very excited and very happy about
this um
it just amuses me to no end i've been
texting about it with friends
i bought one share of gamestop wow i
bought some amc
i bought some blackberry not because i
think i'm going to be rich but just
because i think it's hilarious
i think it's so funny it makes me really
happy
i love that everybody can come together
during this very difficult time
yeah really crossing partisan divides
you know
aoc tweeted uh basically in support of
it and
i think criticizing robin hood and then
like ted cruz retweeted it and said i
agree
uh so it's weird you know um
as divided we are currently politically
it seems that everyone's cool with like
hating on hedge funds i i'm not going to
say ted cruz is quan hating on hedge
funds but
some version of it no considering that
his his roommate and
lover runs one um but
yeah i don't it's kind of like a
variety of emotions on this one because
i think when the story initially broke
just very like funny right off the bat
that uh that a subreddit was able to
create this sort of havoc
in the market and i think it brought up
a bunch of interesting questions because
i think when i was explaining it to my
sister for example
one of her reactions is kind of like
wait that's a that's a thing
like shorting stocks in general is just
a thing and that's a function of the
market
so i think that's been interesting to
watch people realize that um
the stonkers out there and the people on
subreddit weren't doing anything illegal
they were just doing the same type of
market manipulation or legal market
manipulations
that hedge funds and brokers do all the
time i think that's been interesting
in terms of bringing you know larger
focus on how the market actually
functions
i think the downside of it is that like
you know
it's it's a fun little i guess like [ __ ]
you to the system
but it's still just the system playing
by its own
rules and it's not really going to have
any massive long-term effects and i
think everyone now like
expects something like this to happen
again which it probably won't
and you know you would hope this this
would lead to some
larger considerations about the
rationality
and irrationality of markets in general
and i'll be curious to see if that is
something that sustains or if it's
just the meme that that's the lasting
effect of this
and i don't want to hint at anything too
bad but we do have a video
coming out uh on youtube this week that
kind of gets into this in the question
of
you know are markets rational to begin
with and what should we expect of them
so
i don't know i'll be interesting to see
what the like lasting effects of this
are
i'm not particularly optimistic yeah
maybe
i i think the thing that's being under
discussed is
like i i'm fully on board with sentiment
you know people
i mean there's a mixture of people
involved right there are some people
who are just you know very uh interested
in making money and
you know doing a short squeeze and doing
this kind of thing is just like
a a good financial move that hedge funds
do all the time to make more money
um on the other hand there's people who
are not necessarily doing that math i'm
just like i really
want to just stick it to the system i
had friends one was like
am i able to individually buy a stock
like i think this person like had a
retirement account but like didn't
understand that she could like install
robinhood and do this
and said and i and i said yes and i was
like but you know i wouldn't
i wouldn't buy any stock unless you
expect to like fully lose it
you know you shouldn't put five thousand
dollars in game stop at that point and
hope to make all this money
she's just like yeah i know i just want
to hurt these people but that was my
conversation with multiple people
one of my friends you know is an
unemployed service worker
not a ton of money but like you know i
have 200 bucks to you know try to [ __ ]
over a hedge fund
um and so like that's i think the cool
and funny side um but i think
we're already seeing some signs of this
there is also
i think just the a certain mentality of
this is like a good way to get rich in
this sort of like bubbly way
um people are with not a lot of
experience doing things like buying
options which robinhood has been
criticized for sort of allowing people
to do these very risky gambles in the
stock market in the first place
and so for instance there was a reddit
post
uh where you know
the the the headline if anyone wants to
look it up is what gme has taught me in
the 36 hours of
trade day trading basically this person
had no experience day trading
uh saw that hedge funds got lazy and
greedy overshored their positions uh
and so even this is what they said even
if someone knows almost nothing about
the stock market the basic premise makes
sense but the devils and
the details and the hype is binding and
basically talks about how they just lost
a thousand dollars and they're fine but
like
they should have realized all the
warning signs in this and so i think i
mean
being a good pseudo-journalist like i am
i bought two shares of amd at 17
and i have lost 50 of my money now i
lost you know 15 bucks that's fine
but uh you know i'm sure there's lots of
other people who saw the hype and said
am
amc is going to be the the next big
short squeeze i'm going to put a
thousand dollars into that and that's my
entire life savings and then they're
going to go bankrupt and also
another component i worry is you know
i don't think any hedge fund foresaw
reddit being able to do this but now
that they do know how to do this like
these are people
you know the whole idea is one percent
of people own what is it 90 or 95
percent of
the wealth in america people with all
these resources now that they know this
is possible are going to find a way and
hire the best mathematicians and program
the best like trading bots
to figure out a way that even if we're
doing this to [ __ ] us over because
anytime you buy or sell a stock there's
like a winning party and a losing party
and like we have this one quick quick
victory but i think we're gonna lose the
long war
yeah i think i saw someone make that
point that
you know it might have seemed like a
really cool win for the little guy and
this one hedge fund got really screwed
over but then they were like yeah but
there's hundreds of other hedge funds
that are much larger that are going to
take advantage of this in the long run
so the sort of like victory for the
the everyman or the reddit every man
pretty short-lived and symbolic so i
think yeah i think sadly like
i don't want to go too far down a a
socio-economic political rabbit hole but
yeah i think you're right that the
the long-term effect of this will be
those who already
uh have a lot of control over the market
reinforcing themselves even more
and getting out ahead of things like
this in the future but my god it was a
fun 36 hours
i'm concerned about uh what alex said
that people think that they're going to
get rich quick and
i think right now people are so excited
about the stock market because it's
doing well
so people are investing a ton of money
in but what they don't realize is that
it's just doing well right now i mean
you could put your money in most things
and you'll
you'll do pretty well except blackberry
and uh
amc and gamestop like i just found out
yesterday um
but you will do well so you shouldn't
just think like i'll
just keep putting my life savings into
this and get a lot of money because
that's not
sustainable long term yeah and i think
that's the risk too is a lot of people
that don't understand this
are throwing money at like gamestop
still or things like that and think this
is a magic way they're going to make
money which is a bummer
yeah totally i also you know
one part of this is everyone's mad at
robin hood
uh the original uh theory was that they
were
protecting their their buddies at
citadel capital who
loaned melvin capital or was one of the
parties that owned melvin capital total
of like 2.75 billion dollars
uh to get a short position um citadel is
what's called like a market maker
and so that when you buy something on
robinhood they basically go to citadel
to like organize the trade um
according to robin hood this is not why
they did this it was because they needed
like a ton of collateral
they basically didn't have enough money
to do the collateral to like you know
meet all these regulations um now
whether or not they're
this is an excuse or they're telling the
whole truth like that's not really my
point but
i think you know one of the reasons
people like this story is that hedge
funds are basically gambling they
gambled on
the housing market they gambled on all
they gamble on food prices and
you know starve people in developing
countries all the time
and then reddit did a gamble and one and
now they're super mad
um but i think you know wall street bait
that's famously is like full of people
making these awful awful dumb bets doing
these kinds of options trading that
uh maybe shouldn't be legal for people
have no idea what they're doing and
being like i put in three thousand
dollars and somehow i owe robin hood
fifty thousand dollars
um but i think you know there's a great
article that i read that really like
i this is being talked about but i
wonder if it should be more front and
center with the anti-robin hood backlash
is that
you know robin hood's customer is not
you their customers basically
citadel like you are a product that
they're selling to citadel because what
happens is
uh that your trade gets routed to them
and citadel decides like oh you want to
buy this
stock for a dollar but we realize we can
get it for 98 cents
and so we're gonna buy it for 98 cents
and sell it to you for a dollar and
basically skim off the top and share it
with robin hood
and so on all these little trades and if
you know you're using it to buy
index or funds you're probably fine but
like they're
basically just sort of skimming off the
top and
taking from their customers in a way
that's not entirely transparent and
that's that's who robin hood's in
business with like you're just so can
you answer this question for everyone
then
yes or no is is robin hood bad
i think so i mean i i use robinhood and
like i
like i mean i like the the user
interface and
you know i i historically liked it but i
think
um they have in meetings and stuff that
have been leaked like described
as like oh well it's like gambling but
it's not gambling and it's like totally
ethical because i mean when you buy a
stock like confetti pops up and
you know when you go on wall street bets
before all this you see people
basically you know not knowing what
they're doing putting up a lot of money
and losing it which is like
i mean a it's the risk to take but for
people who are super undereducated
and robin hood doesn't care that they
lose that money like that's just more
money for them and their partners you
know
out of curiosity why did you select rob
robin hood over a more established
platform
like uh td ameritrade or something
it was uh when robin hood was kind of
new and they were doing
zero they had no now everyone has no
commission
uh like e-trade and all those places
don't charge a commission for trades but
they were sort of the first to do it
and they're the first to do it because
they
uh it's called purchase for order flow
or something like that it's a it's the
process where they route it to
the market makers and skim off the top
it was also invented by bernie madoff
uh before before the elite the guy with
the mittens and the jacket at the
inauguration yeah yeah yeah that was
cool
um that's bernie madoff so
yeah basically they they were the first
to do it and then e-trade and all these
other places sort of followed suit but
that's why i did it and then it's just
like well
i've got some stocks on there i'll keep
it wow
very interesting too that the most
prominent bernies of the past 10 years
are on very different sides of the uh
let's say ideological and and market
based spectrum that's fun
um any last thoughts on this before we
we transition
hold don't sell because we're going to
the moon
thank you so much wait i wasn't asking
so do you do youtube are you guys do you
guys play the market
are you are you out there rolling dice
on on wall street
making big bucks is that a part of your
lives
well so the answer is sort of no but i
do have a friend
who kind of does and sometimes we'll be
drinking pre-pandemic and be like you
should buy amd stock
and i'll be drunk and on robin hood and
be like all right i'll [ __ ] spend 50
days is that how martha stewart went to
jail a friend told her what to do and
she did it and she was born
that's it that's yeah um so yeah uh dumb
decisions like that but i'm not sitting
around
day trading all day uh i just do
index funds because even though i hate
the stock market i realize it's my only
viable path to retire at some point
uh wow so everyone join the wisecrack
uh patreon so alec can retire one day
um he's that's why that's actually why i
hate to shove it in everyone all the
money
yeah uh i do want to give a shout out
though
speaking of money to two people in the
chat
specifically sorry for the delay first
zombie bait we like the stock diamond
hands rocket ships thank you so much
and of course dude abides who's watching
more sports and crime docs
so yeah be curious to hear if you're
still in the chat two divides
uh drop what your favorite 30 for 30s
are for everyone doesn't know 3430 is a
series of documentaries produced by espn
that are actually really good
i'm curious to hear which one he's
watching there's been some great sports
documentaries recently either you all
watch the tiger woods thing
no okay well you know the thing about
tiger woods
is he was getting a lot of trouble
having affairs and stuff but what could
have benefited him is if he had
a body double because then he could have
been in two places at one time and had
an
alibi so he could have said to his wife
elon no i wasn't in vegas with 10 women
in a hotel doing an elaborate role
player thing with a bunch of sex workers
i was here playing golf for here with my
kids so serbia is going to tell us
about the wonderful world of body
doubling
and hand modeling i think if i have this
correctly and i'm very excited to hear
about this so so
every smooth transition yes that's what
i'm known for
informing i appreciated it so i want to
talk about body doubles today and for
those of you who don't know a body
double
is a person who substitutes an actor
in a scene for another actor um so
sometimes they're used when
someone is like in the background
and that actor isn't needed on screen to
like
say lines or sometimes it might be for
like a nude scene
so kieran knightley for example once
said i have this policy in films where i
say
you can have the top half but you can't
have the bottom half
and she has a body double for the
striptease scene
in domino and i'm talking about body
doubles today because my best friend got
a text
a couple days ago out of the blue from a
random number
and a woman mistakenly sent her this
text
uh about a casting call for a hand
double
and i'm going to read the casting note
for all of you
thank you so the subject says female
hand models needed for tuesday
and then it says casting specs two
females in their twenties we will only
see their hands
the action and nola homes hands a 19th
century envelope to a recipient
these are the people who are needed one
caucasian hand to play the role of enola
homes
and one ethnically diverse hand to be
the female recipient
fingernails should be clean no color
fingernail polish just natural no
jewelries or tattoos
we will shoot on tuesday at
such and such place time is tbd uh
so my friend got this text and the woman
said oh i saw this i thought of you
um i have the two pictures of you i have
that
i have two pictures of your hand but it
would be great to have a real-life photo
so if you could send that to me i'll
send it to the producer
um so my friend like looks at her hand
she takes a picture of it
um well i think she first asks how much
like what is the cos like what is the
price for this and the woman tells her
that to be a hand model
it's six thousand dollars just to hand
an envelope
six thousand dollars for your hand
um and so my friend's like yeah do they
have a union
the the hand model union the hand model
union is very
has a lot of clout um and so
my friend's like that sounds great is it
this tuesday um
and mind you my friend does not know who
this woman is it's just a random number
um so uh the woman's like i'm not sure
i'm getting more details blah blah send
me a picture of your hand
so before my friend can send the picture
to
the woman the woman says the the role
has been filled but she'll keep
her in mind for future roles um
so anyway we started my friend and i
started to talk about
how she felt bad about herself after
looking at her hand
and thinking that she couldn't be a hand
model and
uh we talked about how celebrities use
doubles for everything and is anything
real anymore like everything is
photoshopped in magazines
everything is edited in films um and now
we have body doubles and now we have
hand models just to do
whatever an important question here yeah
sorry to interrupt alex maybe you're
going down the same rabbit hole down
here
do we know this is a real thing and not
just a scammer that has a hand fetish
that texts random women and says this to
get hand picks
no no no it's real because the it has
the
uh the company name
um oh okay and like it's like from uh
like an agency or something like a
casting agency okay
um my my my question was actually so
wait this means that like millie bobby
brown
is like i refuse to show my hands on
camera or
so i don't think it was for the netflix
show i think it was for something else
like an award show okay
so um yeah but i mean yeah
yeah it could be something for like the
golden globes or whatever they do like a
bit
where it's like people from different
shows passing an envelope to see who the
winner is or something
and i guess maybe rather than paying to
fly millie bobby brown out for that you
just get someone with like
a white hand she would charge twelve
thousand dollars versus six thousand
dollars
maybe she charged 20. listen if somebody
wants to charge
pay me six grand for my hand i'll give
it to him
yeah let's all audition our hands right
now for the uh
i could be the ethnically diverse hand i
mean here's one thing i like about this
um it creates more jobs it spreads
things out in the industry i like that
like why not
have more people working right now in
this economy
that sounds fine and i actually the
first thing you brought up serbia i
saw that kieran knightley piece or
interview as well which i thought was
interesting
and like stuff like that i get you know
why people
wouldn't want to show intimate parts of
their body on screen and i think that's
a kind of nice fix so that people can
do what they want to do creatively and
artistically without forcing someone
to be vulnerable at that level
and then like the hand model thing i
understand for advertising
isn't there a seinfeld where george
becomes a hand model
oh i think you're there's there's an
episode revolving around hand modeling
there's some yeah hand modeling science
episodes that's a different
difference a couple hand related
episodes but yeah but the idea that
so so i know we don't know what this
particular thing is for
if it were a thing we're on an actual tv
show on set
there was a thing where it was like okay
millie's offset because in the next
scene there's just a hand bring in the
hands
that seem pretty crazy yeah i mean i
wouldn't
things are so weird that i wouldn't even
bat an eye at that like to i don't think
that's outside the realm of possibility
and i say this because
a girl i went to college with was a
model and she's stunning
and a few years ago she was the body
double for
a supermodel for a commercial
and the supermodel is like giselle level
supermodel
um and it struck me so strange because
she posted about this talking about her
body double work and
what the supermodel did and what she did
in this commercial and it
seemed to me that the supermodel didn't
ask for a body double just to save time
on set
or to like like decrease her
responsibilities or something she
was there watching this girl film like
the supermodel was literally just
standing there watching
watching this girl like prance back and
forth and it felt so sad to me that this
woman
who many people believe is
conventionally beautiful and
has a nice body feels that she needs to
have a 20
year old represent her instead so
maybe she has a really jealous partner
who has retrograde views of things like
that
and says no no gal of mine
will be prancing around in a commercial
yeah i don't know
i mean that's possible but probably not
that no
who knows i just thought it was strange
i mean she showed pictures of the
supermodel there
on set and i'm like why are you having
her do your work
also i'm shocked that your friend didn't
have to sign an nda because i feel
like part of the mystery for things like
this would be not letting it get out
when body doubles were used so i think
she did
but there were paparazzi um
who saw because it was filmed somewhere
in europe i think like on a bridge
or like on a street or something like
that
so everybody was around taking pictures
and that's where i think there was like
a whole thing in the press about how
like why does the supermodel use a body
double
this makes me think if you know i don't
know if we get the budget for this would
be great to do an episode of this where
we all had a body double we could do a
casting call find someone for
for each of us and just have them take
over we could still record our voices
and then they would have to lip-sync to
the entire thing
or no they would just stand in like when
we're not talking
like we just go in and out and then
they'd like nah they're heading back
yep yep so i kind of cut like that and
then my body they would come in
and say things like hmm that's brilliant
i've always wanted a nemesis and i feel
like this is
the first step in that wait you've
always wanted a nemesis you've never had
one
no i mean i've had people i hate you
just need to invent your own
survey i mean i invent nemesis all the
time you do
like people you know are just like
really just imaginative ones
no i like there is a person in my life
that they don't know that i'm having a
competition with them but i'm having a
competition with them
whoa this is um the author roxanne
gay has talked about this on her twitter
before how she has a nemesis and she
encourages other people to have one
yeah um i find so so it's a real person
that's that's great
i do think it can be motivating to have
a nemesis but it can also sometimes
uh create unfair levels of comparison
for oneself
yeah it's not a comparison like it's not
a comparison thing
it's uh i'm i might consider myself a
petty person
uh and this person i know like is really
obsessed with their twitter
following and i'm not there yet but i
just want more twitter followers
than them i don't care about my twitter
followers i just want them to feel bad
about me having
more twitter followers again because i'm
petty yeah we'll get to this at the end
but everyone obviously follow alec on
twitter so he can devastate the psyche
of his nemesis
um i i mean i hey i think everyone
should have one and if you if you have a
nemesis you know drop it in the chat
tell us about it later i think we would
love
to hear about various nemesis
uh that people have we should bring that
back maybe that should be a new theme
rather than we should use slaps chaps
and nemesis and we can talk about
the the nemesis we have in our lives
yeah serbia also asked me if my nemesis
was matpat and i will say no it's not
first of all there's no way i'm ever
that dude is
a million times whatever that would be a
dumb nemesis to have but he's not my
nemesis he's a very nice man
mine is bobby flay if you are watching
this bobby
[ __ ] you i'll out grill you i will out
anything you i think you're a piece
i'm kidding i love bobby flay um real
irish american hero
um i think any other things on the body
doubles now that we've completely
digressed into talking about
nemesis i if you are a body double
please write in and share your
experiences
if you have any body double stories also
please uh
share that because i'm very fascinated
about this world of
doubling yeah you know what a good use
for a body double will be i'll say this
you know how in people's weddings they
get married and then everyone else goes
and starts to get finger foods and
cocktails
but the people that got married have to
go to some separate room and take a
bunch of dumb pictures for like an
hour everyone else is having fun do a
body double for that
so then you can hang out and have a
cocktail and then i mean i guess your
wedding pictures which you would hold on
to forever wouldn't be
you but who cares yeah who cares right
get someone who's like a slightly better
looking version of you so when you're
old it's still believable
yeah that's free advice for you um now
i'll
i'm gonna get to my topic now this is
this will be a quick one and this is
i'll say this is like a
borderline crowdsourcing thing so i'm
very curious to hear both what my
esteemed colleagues
alec and serbia think about this but if
you are watching live right now
i'm curious what you think about this
one if you're listening after the fact
i'm curious about this but i've been
obsessed recently with the idea
that our culture has gotten really corny
um and taken an aggressive corny turn
i'll talk about why i think that is and
i'm just curious to hear what you guys
think
um and i'll say this as well i think
that corniness
is related to but not the same thing as
cringe culture
in doing some preliminary research a lot
of people conflate those two
but there's a relation there i'll start
this like any
mediocre high school graduation speech
starts
the dictionary defines horny acetrite
banal are mockishly sentimental
um now there's not a lot of good
definitions of corny out there but
that's
you know our dictionary thing one thing
i think of
when i think about corniness as well is
occupying a space
that's neither serious enough nor
funny enough or irreverent enough this
kind of middle space
where it's not occupying interesting
thought or something that's like
funny or interesting so i'll give some
examples of places where i see corniness
in our culture
the first one i'll say it'll get me just
canceled and devastated and i don't care
we've talked about disney adults before
on this i think the disney adult
phenomenon kind of a corny thing a part
of our culture where adults get obsessed
with with reliving these childhood
fantasies i'm someone that watches
superhero movies regularly so i'm not
judging but it's kind of corny
another thing that i think is sort of
for me the paragon
of corniness and contemporary culture is
hamilton
now i i watched hamilton i didn't pay a
million dollars to see it i watched it
on tv but
you know it's it's a good production i
think there's nothing wrong with
enjoying something like that
but hamilton has been treated like this
work of art this important cultural
phenomenon
when it's like a musical theater nerds
fantasy about the founding fathers being
both like
really good guys and also rappers um
rather than doing let's say like the
serious work of trying to speak truth to
power and talking about our history
or doing something just funny and
irreverent it kind of like re-writes the
truth so that the powerful were always
the good guys and this is another thing
i think
i notice about corniness corniness
rarely
questions things or speaks truth to
power and we can see this like whenever
we talk about disney on wisecrack
we get roasted and i have to like watch
some video that some youtube channel
made where my face is on it for 45
minutes in slow motion it makes me
really upset
um but but one reason you'll get upset
is because we let's say
question like is disney always good
are there some problematic things there
the same thing with hamilton i know the
first couple years that was out
i knew a lot of people that had a
hesitancy to speak ill of it because you
would just get
roasted if you said anything bad about
it which to me seems unhelpful
now hamilton also relates to a moment in
our culture and this one
i'm going to walk on eggshells here but
um everyone got really excited a couple
weeks ago
about um amanda gorman's inaugural poem
at the presidential inauguration great
poet uh
los angeles local but the poem like
references
hamilton in the poem and the cultural
reaction to this poem there was one
tweet i forget who said it but it said
something like
enjoying watching um amanda gorman's
poetry reading
featuring joe biden's inauguration and
there was this whole like
culture of obsession around this thing
where it couldn't just be
that you know someone gave a decently
middle brow
poetry reading at the inauguration it
had to be like
this is the best person in the world
this is the best poem ever
i would die for this person and of
course you look at the twitter response
and within seconds it was like amanda
gorman for president
and it's like not everyone has to be the
president just because they read a poem
um but that kind of made me think of
this
i'm going to do a couple more jump
arounds and i'll see what you guys think
which then made me think as well about
the continued obsession with something
like the west wing
either of you all watch the west wing no
but i've seen like
clips of weird aaron sorkin written
speeches
yes and you know this is maybe an aaron
sorkin problem in general
but there's this continued obsession
with the west wing and this idea that
like
wow this is what would be good this is
what we should describe
like subscribe to as a society this is
what we should be aiming for but it's
like a pretty corny over earnest show
that completely skirts over the like
complexity of reality
which that makes me think well of like
reboot culture how it
seems like our generation rather than
wanting like
new or challenging narratives we just
want repurposed versions of the old
stuff
that makes us feel good um now i haven't
watched the new save by the bell people
seem to like it a lot but like that
makes me think of it this idea that we
just have to have the old stuff that
makes us feel good
and that in all of these sort of stories
we're just running back the same
narratives
um now i'll give my charitable reading
and my uncharitable reading of corniness
and corny culture and i'm genuinely
curious if you guys think so my
charitable read of this is that
you know we live in a rough time for a
variety of reasons
and people just want to cope with our
harsh reality
and a retreat into corniness
in in culture and art and music and
politics is just a
creating like a low-stakes world where
every story has a moral narrative and
the good guys always win
and we can fantasize about our heroes
and make memes about how like we wish
the president was our daddy and the vice
president was our mommy and we were a
happy family
which isn't me making stuff up that was
all over twitter last week
now my uncharitable reading of of the
corny shift in culture
is that it's a genuinely damaging
ideological structure
that blinds people from like thinking
critically about reality
and leads to this fetishizing of public
figures and systems of power
which make it both impossible and or
just like uncouth
to criticize beloved cultural figures
which i think is
is very dangerous like if we can't if we
can't without getting roasted
be a little bit critical or skeptical of
things um i think it can create this
like
veil or shield but once again these are
initial thoughts i've been obsessed with
this recently and i'm very curious what
you all think
can i can i ask some question like i
just want to figure out what is corny
and what is not i know you gave some
examples but like
live live laugh love decor corny or is
that something else
wait live laugh what love love
is that a phrase from some company uh
you know
it's like on a bunch of merchandise like
okay yeah yeah like in this house we
laugh a lot we love a lot
we drink a lot of wine you know like the
yeah yeah so i would say like
like the the branded version of like
self-care culture i think is very corny
okay
so like phrases yeah yeah i think i
think things like that can get very
corny yes
uh what about uh bridgerton if you've
seen it is that corny
ooh i haven't seen it but it doesn't
strike me as corny
serbia you have seen it do you think
it's corn i have seen it the sex
scenes are odd forward through all of
them none of them are good
very uncomfortable every person i've
ever talked to
they were all women are like we love the
sex scenes so i don't know what you're
talking about but
really sex scenes aren't corny corny
stuff avoids sex or sex is just like
cute yeah i think bridgeton might be
corny
because it's like isn't being a royal
fun and cool
um but yeah yeah oh i got a corny
example real quick too i don't know if
anyone saw this
the day of the presidential inauguration
the white rapper macklemore
put out a new freezer but but
see that i think we got some problems
here because like
macklemore corny but it's like you know
like the things he's saying i'm not
necessarily disagreeing with he just
does say in a corny fashion
that's a good point i'm still figuring
this all out yeah we're trying to work
through this yeah so corny would be
something where it's like everybody
jumps on the bandwagon kind of thing and
it leaves no room for
an opposite opinion yeah like if you
hate the corner
thing you're a bad person okay i just
wouldn't call that corny like i think i
grew up thinking corny was like
silly or dumb um like a corny dad joke
kind of thing like i don't know what
word i would use to describe
well i guess too it's like the current
use of corniness because i totally agree
with you i think
corny has always meant one thing and i
think it's starting to mean something
different or like
corniness is going from dumb dad joke
to like a full-on cultural sensibility
and i think that's what i find so
fascinating yeah so back to your
original question about what we thought
about it
i hate it i feel like i don't share a
lot of opinions anymore about things
um like even now i have thoughts about
the amanda gorman uh poem
i will not share them on this podcast i
will not share anything about
we need to know sir no because
i feel like as soon as you say anything
like yeah i was good
but like here i'll say something that
veils us from any direct criticism
um i live with a poet um who's friends
with a lot of poets
none of the poets liked it okay so then
that makes me feel a little bit better
so i thought it was fine
but i didn't think that it was deserving
of as much praise
and like people said it was like
life-changing and maybe it is
life-changing for a lot of people like
i'm not discounting people's experiences
but
the response did not see it seemed
disproportionate to
the poem like i think it's amazing that
she's so young and she spoke so
eloquently and things like that like
that's incredible
but in terms of the actual content it
like it didn't
i don't know i feel like i've read other
poems on the internet by no name
people that have felt more powerful to
me
um but i tried to say that to somebody
and they were like how could you say
that like this was
this was this is going to affect change
like her words will
and i think that's part of the corny
cult it's a sort of like earnestness
but not even like a good sort of
earnestness it's this intensity
of of latching on to something in this
real
like formal way that precludes the
possibility
of acknowledging that something's like
just fine or okay or that your friend
cannot like the thing and it doesn't
make them a monster i
i wonder if it's like i attach corniness
or associate with corneas
sort of like a a sincereness and
authenticity
like in the way that you describe like
as uncritical
um and so like dad jokes are sincere and
authentic but uncritical about like how
stupid they are but that's sort of
part of it or um
you know i i think maybe the problem
with the west wing for instance
is that like it is a show that packages
like
quote unquote and maybe that's what it
is quote unquote sincere authentic
emotions in terms of like political
speech giving
that like is uncritical in a way that
thinks like you know if
uh mr smith just goes to washington and
speaks for eight hours
all the bad men will go away and i think
like that's the problem
uh like like you said like the good
versus evil uh
like there's always a triumphant side i
think there's part of this again
politically with like homosexuals where
it's just like
and you know like yeah that's a great
example he he just like made this great
joke about like
chin diapers and it was a funny joke but
like again there's this
sincerity or like a perceived sincerity
authenticity
please be my daddy i'm not gonna ask
questions about like what's going on and
then later we'll be like just kidding
we're opening
dinner for thanksgiving have fun
everyone
yeah and i do want to say this just to
demarcate for anyone who's wondering
listening to this
when i say too that like i think
corniness precludes criticism
i don't mean this in some like cancel
culture way where it's like we should be
able to talk about what everyone no
there's certain stuff that's just like
messed up
that's bad that's you know racist that's
dark that's violent we shouldn't talk
about
um but it's the idea that certain things
like
are too precious to be discussed or
criticized or pointed out as wrong i
think that's why i'm trying to you know
mostly using like kind of
pop culture examples or even like all i
think all the politics stuff we're
saying
it's even how like politics is being
treated like pop culture
like television um like the sort of way
we like
fetishize a superhero and that's why i
find it like less problematic
if a friend is like really into comics
and likes cosplay and is over obsessed
with a certain character whatever that's
fine
for me i find it more problematic when
we treat public figures like that
yeah and when corniness creeps into
areas where corniness maybe shouldn't be
yeah although there i think there's a
corniest like i mean we've talked about
wanda vision where
you know you like it more than i do i
thought the
last episode was good um and
it's not like how dare you like wand
division or how dare you like this
amanda gorman thing but it's a sort of
like
it's that sort of like emotional sincere
attachment where just like i'm so
overwhelmed by like
i'm almost in awe of like how great and
attached i feel to this thing and again
i don't know like maybe corny's not the
the right word maybe it's stan culture
you know
yeah i think it's definitely a version
of that too um
you know wisecrack director uh mike lux
had a good tweet about this
uh the one division thing where it said
something like all these people talking
about it being like
magical incredible visionary filmmaking
and it's like no
but it's fine and that's also okay and i
think it's that middle ground that some
of this like corny stan culture
precludes
the inability to say that something is
fine or someone's okay or a thing is
complicated
or like i really enjoyed it but you know
it's not
the greatest piece of media that's ever
been created and like that's fine too
like you know
there's plenty of star trek that i think
is [ __ ] amazing but i wouldn't be
like
and this is why it's objectively the
best tv show ever you know
yeah well it almost feels similar to
like a lot of
startup cultures are like this like it's
almost like toxic positivity like
no one can say anything bad like always
be happy
good vibes only and it's like that that
leaves no room for people to be actual
humans
yeah that's a really good point and yeah
i do think a lot of contemporary
startup cult and i think that started to
bleed into like work culture more
generally
where like we all have to be all in on
the thing together believing in the
mission and it's like
dog let people just like do their thing
and like be able to pay their rent don't
make them become
uh you know ideologues along the way
i will say my nemesis was corny and i
would say
toxically positive wow
well this is great um go ahead serbie oh
no
no i have nothing more yeah any final
thoughts before we transition away from
this
no i mean i think it's okay to disagree
it's okay to think
things are not cool for example the poem
yeah and i'll say this to go off with
serbia's saying i think both sides
are cool it's okay to not think
something's good but that also doesn't
mean you have to like [ __ ] on it and say
people that do like it are idiots and
sometimes i think that's where our
culture is it's like either
this is the best poem ever and this
person should be our new overlord or
it's total crap in all culture is bad
and i think that like
either of those extremes can be
problematic and i don't know what the
other side of corny is maybe it's just
like toxic cynicism towards toxic
positivity that's where i'm at
every day i know um well it's been
helpful and i'll say this um
i want to keep thinking about this so i
would love if you're
if you're listening right now or
watching let us know what you think
about that and if i ever write something
on this i'll footnote you
and let us know what you think about any
of these topics or let us know about
what you think
about topics we haven't even discussed
and you can do that in a couple ways one
is that you can email us at culturebinge
wisecrack dot co no m culture binge at
wisecrack.com
as always um just so you know we don't
always get to read
every email that we get um on the show
but we read them all we like them all i
know personally ever since
i got added to the thing where i get to
see the emails now they finally gave me
those privileges it's like being in the
cia
i love reading them i find them so
interesting there's never a time where
it isn't really meaningful that you all
take the time
to write out thoughtful emails or
recommendations to us even if they're
critical
um you can also call us because we love
to hear your voices you all have great
voices
uh two one three five three four eight
eight eight zero seven's where you can
call us that's two in three five three
four eight eight zero seven
um so get in touch with us we like to
hear from you
even if we don't you don't make the show
your first time around
we see you we hear you and we'll put you
on eventually
that said uh what what do we want to
take a a reader listen to this week alec
we got one voicemail from cole but
before we play it uh i do want to shout
out gcr who says i blame
i blame retweets for corny culture it's
not it's not a terrible hypothesis but
anyway let's get to cole
left us a voicemail about snitching on
people during a pandemic
as we know snitches get stitches but
maybe they don't
it's very ambiguous joy can you play
that uh hey
this is for culture range this is cole
calling
uh a long time listener i've called him
before uh real quick at the top marmot
apologized to michael
last time i called and i called you by a
nickname today boo
call him by that nickname every day that
was my apologies for calling you that
nickname anyway
my point that i wanted to um make was
that uh you guys talked about uh the
carton arcs on your last episode and you
want to do something like that for
covid well i'm part of the lgbtq plus
community um and as a queer man i follow
one of the pages that i absolutely love
called gays over kovid
and they spent a significant a portion
of their time
um calling out a lot of people in the
gay community especially
um in the the male gay community who are
taking time to go to like mexico tulum
puerto vallarta
to celebrate and gather like outside of
the u.s
um but also that's extremely problematic
for all the reasons you know
but yeah if you haven't check out gays
over covet because they are
calling out like doctors who have gone
out and traveled to mexico and other
places
and a bunch of other people in the queer
community who are
vacationing and hanging out with friends
during this panasonic
so um yeah thank you all for all you do
servie
michael and alec you are wonderful
individuals and all of the other
wonderful researchers writers
and um presenters at wisecrack have a
great afternoon
night morning wherever you are and thank
you again bye-bye i i love this email i
i hope panasonic
not yeah love cole i kind of hope
that's intentional is that it i hope so
i hope it was a corny joke
because we love corniness here no uh
he has such a nice sounding voice yeah
keep keep calling cool
seems like such a nice guy i want to be
friends with him oh
don't be so corny don't get obsessed
with cole don't stand him he's a
person you know he has flaws too i
i'm kind of i'm kind of curious like i
had like
kind of heard or maybe you know certain
screenshots from gays over covet
landed in my timeline at some point um
and like on one hand i'm all about like
yeah if you're part of a community and
your community or parts of your
community are being shitty
be like [ __ ] you stop doing that and i
think that's sort of like the ethos of
this page but also i think it's gotten
some flack you know
the thing you don't want to do is like
everyone's being a dumb [ __ ] why are
you singling out like this one specific
group
like you know uh gay people and so
i mean i think as like cole you're in
that community
not that's not about you but i think if
it was like me being like everyone go
check this out and go look at like
what all these people are doing um but i
do think like
yeah i mean those people on that page
are the [ __ ] worst
there's lots of people that are the
worst but they're among them you know
yeah we had a lot of words right now it
makes me think of i haven't seen that
page i'm gonna look it up
i saw someone the other day that posted
there a doctor from los angeles of
course
that was on a trip and like it was like
tulum or something like that and she was
like posting all these pictures
of her in like swimsuits on the beach
ring cocktails and the hashtag was like
vaccinated coved because and like the
thing was like got my vaccine and ready
to travel it's like you're a [ __ ]
doctor and you don't get how this works
um it's pretty infuriating yeah
so so yeah anything that's but it is
it's such a fine line between
in general i think snitching is is a
horrible thing
i don't like it it makes me mad but when
it comes to public health
i don't know i i i make some exceptions
i don't know i love that kind of [ __ ]
like i remember when there was a drought
in california
and like i loved life some counties had
like restrictions like you were only
allowed to
like water your grass like twice a week
and only on these days
and i wanted to call the county to see
if there was like a task force i could
join
where i could like my whole job was just
to go around the neighborhood like
saying this guy's watering his grass
when he's not supposed to suit he's on
tuesday thursday's schedule and it's
wednesday
um i just love that stuff like
i don't know what's wrong with me i just
find so much joy
and like like making sure everybody's
following the rules
yeah i'm that person too and i don't
know why because like politically i'm
like [ __ ] the rules [ __ ] the system but
on a personal level it's like i need to
follow literally all the rules if
i'm with family members who want to cut
in line i'm like don't do that you're
going to make me have a panic attack
yeah maybe it's anxiety it's just like
extreme anxiety where i'm like everybody
must follow the rules we will not have
water
we must have water yeah um i'm a hippie
about so many things but like line
cutters like i will throw you in
in a jail and or a work camp and feel
nothing yeah
um cool well thank you for that cole i
believe
there should be more again i'm a petty
person more petty snitching
on everything but not about maybe some
things anyway
uh we got a lot of great emails uh we'll
see how many we can get through but one
is from an
anonymous professor asked to have their
name
oh yeah well they had their name in
there but they asked us to take it out
but last week
uh burns was complaining about a certain
professor
who like threw a bunch of papers in the
air and was like this is what it's like
when you don't give me a proper
salutation my email
and this professor has a great uh
counterpoint not a counterpoint that
they disagree with burns but like a
great
added perspective it's a good
perspective yeah uh so
i'm a limited duties lecturer of an
online class uh in
emails my students call me all kinds of
things ranging from first name
they put their real name uh to hey to
other people's names entirely i never
correct them
but i keep signing my name with doctor
last name insert last name
up until a couple weeks ago before i
started teaching i was determined to
sign emails with my first name as is
common in canada i also wanted to be a
cool professor
two things changed my mind first bench
peer and others uh
began arguing with dr jill biden should
not call herself doctor
because she has a doctorate in education
and he thinks only people with a
doctorate in stem or medical
doctors deserve to use that title i i
mean i
i believe we should all call you dr
nihilism for the record burns but anyway
a movement has since been on social
media encouraging women with phds to
call themselves doctor
second other young female professors
encouraged me to use doctor rather than
my first name at least for a few years
so that students would respect my
authority
sorry i had to do that in the carmen
voice i am 27 and look pretty young
during my time as a teaching assistant i
noticed that
the mostly white male students would
fight me for grades and try to
intimidate me
like raise their voice lean over me get
in my personal space complain about me
to other professors
much more than my male counterparts i
tried talking to my male professors
about this but they said that i was too
nice and needed to command respect from
the students
eventually i realized that if i dressed
more formally than students wore makeup
smile less etc i could reduce the amount
of complaints to almost zero
as a professor i want to be encouraged
to be friendly to students calling
myself doctor last name
allows me to be myself while i'm
maintaining a bit of authority
that said i would never force students
call me doctor last name nor would i
shame them in the for the email
etiquette
but yeah i mean i've heard a lot of uh
i have a few professor teachers uh
women who like have these same things
like dressing older
putting on like more makeup to look
older even though they normally don't
wear
makeup um you know
weird things where like your default
for every single professor is usually
either calling them professor or doctor
but all of a sudden like uh a woman's
teaching the class you're like oh hi
miss
and it's like no no like why aren't you
yeah but that makes sense
and like i think the the irony of the
the dynamic is and of course too like i
get that it's it's
much worse and it very much sucks to
that like students
treat women worse than they would their
their male professors it's [ __ ]
um but there is a thing i think when
you're in your 20s and you're teaching
college students
i think regardless of who you are i
think there is sometimes like is i think
that's when i was first teaching i was
in my mid-20s
and i would wear like blazers and ties
and it's made fun of sometimes my
friends who are like when you were 25
you dressed like you were 40 and now
that you're
30 something you're dressed like you're
seven do you have pictures can we i need
to say yeah i can get you some
but i think like and then early on i did
say i would always say like dr
burns because i think i was like i
wanted to be taken seriously
but then the older i got the more you
know once i was
10 years or more older than the students
it was easier to do
so i definitely i have a lot more
understanding for like that
the description of that situation than i
do of let's say like a tenured professor
who's like
shaming students for not signing an
email the right way yeah
but some of the things she described
there like students intimidating leaning
over like [ __ ] those dudes
i felt so bad when i read that yeah i
kept thinking about it for weeks
afterwards
i mean the email only probably came in
like last week or whatever but i've been
thinking about it since then
um and reflecting back on my experiences
with female professors when i was in
school
and i went to a small uh private
university so it was the same like five
professors in every department
um and i don't believe that
they encounter that just i mean i don't
really know but
i never saw it but i think it's because
it was like the school was really small
the faculty like everything was really
small you couldn't get away with that
um and then in business school everybody
was a little bit older
but i did notice in business school a
lot of my female professors would dress
very very professionally like suits
every day sort of thing um it just makes
me so
sad that even in even there's like no no
industry where like a woman can get away
with just
being herself you always will uh
encounter
some white dude trying to [ __ ] you over
i i will say so like the second part of
this email like i 100 agree with
and i certainly understand the first
part of the email about the whole dr joe
biden thing
jill biden sounded like i said joe biden
um
like i feel like there's a risk when
like people are shitty there's like an
opposite and equal reaction in the
opposite that's not it's not as shitty
it's not like that but i feel like
walking around being like everyone must
refer to me as doctor like
that's and i don't i don't have evidence
of anyone actually doing that but i
think in this sort of like
make sure to get everyone uh to call you
doctor because
people aren't taking you know joe biden
seriously um
you know certainly not on the side of
[ __ ] ben shibibo or whatever but like
i don't know i i work with many phds
including dr niles and burns and like if
he was ever like uh
alec you need to call me doctor i'd be
like go [ __ ] yourself and if anyone else
did i'd say go [ __ ]
and i would immediately file an hr
complaint that i was being harassed by
my superior
and i would see you in court where you
would refer to me as doctor
yeah and a plaintiff and i think that
applies for everything like i also used
to work with medical doc
and i i think it's just like my
experiences i worked with a lot of
medical doctors none of them expected to
be called
doctor except you know to their patients
which makes sense again like if you're
in a
university setting uh i i worked in a
congressional office where i got in
trouble for
not calling a judge your honor and i was
like you suck [ __ ] you
you know when i i always put doctor the
one thing i do is i've
put doctor before on both like airline
stuff like if i'm booking a flight i'll
put doctor as my prefix because
sometimes i feel like if they're like
have to upgrade someone they might see
that and be like ooh
and then when i register for a new like
primary care physician i do
and i do it because in that way i don't
have to call them doctor because then i
can be like okay
[Laughter]
yeah and my current primary care
physician great great gentleman his name
is michael as well so we just call each
other michael it feels great yeah yeah
so the airline thing i think you should
be careful with because they might think
that you're a medical doctor
oh no yeah i killed someone this guy
went down
hard and i was just like whispering
lines from plato in his ear as the life
left his eyes and was like there's
nothing more i can do
i'm kidding uh serbia how are you doing
on time we have a few more emails but we
can
depend on how you're doing yeah i can do
a little bit longer okay uh just let me
know
okay so thank you an honest professor
great email
thank you so much um here's a great one
about
uh from craig on hilaria baldwin for
those who don't recall that
is hilarious hilaria baldwin that is
yeah alec
put some respect on her culture yeah uh
alec baldwin's wife who lied about being
from spain
for decades maybe um so anyway in
regards to that story i
from greg i have my craig i have my own
experience with upper class white folks
who stretch their identities to get some
social significance points my cousin
recently got into med school because she
applied for the indigenous
person slot we are one 32nd inuit in my
family and have no connection to their
culture
but no other first nations people
applied so she got into med school using
a vague ancestral tie my thought is that
people sometimes use perceived
victimhood sas as a fashionable trait to
font these days sometimes they can share
with their friends over a patio brunch
with mimosas like it's a new
to your purse whether it's real or
perceived victimhood stats flaunting it
to others as some kind of hot new
fashion
item feels morally abhorrent and
contradicts the person
purposes of recognizing accepting
people's unique identities
do you all have any stories of other
people's celebrities using
victimhood sas in a cringy way as a
person with one thirty second
nation first nations ancestry you must
read this email on the next episode or
you're silencing me
i thought i laughed at that i really put
a gun to our head there uh
there is uh god i'm gonna get speaking
of corny culture i'm gonna get murdered
for this this is how
elizabeth warren got a job before she
was at congress uh before she was you
know in government
harvard law job applied as an indigenous
person
even though i forget the numbers she won
100th 1 1000th
something she claimed she didn't know
that she was that
little i think it was like in the 132 or
164th range but
it was i just said you shouldn't get
cancelled for this because
heart there's harvard publicized it as
their first
non-white law professor or something
like that
yeah it's not so good i can't think of
it that's so good there i i mean um do
you know that in this in the university
like state new york system or whatever
it is that italian americans are
considered
uh like a minority group yeah i saw that
really i think it's something
i think it's just like something really
old on the law because you know in new
york like 100 years ago 150 years ago
they were super shitty to italians
and they thought that you know all these
catholics were having too many babies it
was because of garlic and all this [ __ ]
it was it was all dumb and racist and it
was bad but i think it's still in the
book
i've i've like heard italian americans
before get
real close to saying things like they're
technically non-white
yeah i mean things have changed in 150
years that's all i'll say or 100 years
oh yeah to be clear i've heard people
say this
in years like 2019 and not like 1911.
yeah
so yeah i know but i do feel like there
is
i can't think of like a ton of concrete
examples but yeah it's a thing that a
lot of like white people
a vaguely european ancestry love to do
oh and if i know somebody who did that
she got into uh grad school that way and
she got like i think a 50
scholarship too um and she has no idea
if she is
even indigenous american she just had
heard
that they were um somewhere in the line
and she's like okay i'll apply that way
she got in and she had all the
scholarship money because of it yeah
oh do you remember when mindy kalin's
brother did this by pretending to be
black and getting into medical school
what
he made a whole website about it do you
guys not know the story no mindy
kaling's
little brother who who i'm pretty sure
is of indian descent
um like posed as black
and applied to like i think it was like
emery or something for medical school
and got in and then like
i think he like made a website about it
to be like
look i proved something about like
affirmative action or discrimination
it's the most
cringe messed up weird thing not good
ever yeah um so you just google mindy
kaling brother
and once again that's not a poor
reflection on mindy kaling who creates
great content i you know we're not
responsible for our siblings just to
make sure i'm not throwing
people under the bus uh that's weird
cool
so let's go on to
here's i'm not gonna read that
uh i'm not gonna read the whole thing
but username donated and
wants to ask how you deal with sim
trolls like me how do you continue the
conversation i don't know if you want to
respond to that
what's a simp troll uh sims are people
uh now let's
let's just move on i
remember this the day that survey
learned what a simple was and that she
had that yeah just just
go google it later
was this question for me yeah like i
have some trouble yeah i don't
i mean if you want to engage with it
that's your prerogative but whatever
we'll teach you about later yeah okay um
all right the last email is from
uh let's do email from joe
uh sent us a news story that i thought
was really interesting i'm curious about
your opinions on this story about my
fellow canadians
uh it's about canadian snowbirds those
are people who vacation in florida
and other places in the south i think
going from canada to florida to get
vaccinated earlier uh in canada it's
upset a lot of us to hear so many older
folks traveling to florida we call them
canadian snowbirds in the middle of
pandemic even though i was
it was highly discouraged and the border
was closed what are your
impromptu reactions how are they getting
in if the border's closed
well maybe it's not close i i have no
idea also i know with the border
it's like you cannot drive over the
border but you can fly
there's all these like weird rules that
don't make any sense and maybe
you know if you own a property in
florida i mean i'll say my reaction is
that
uh you know it's not that like these
people aren't over 65 and if they're
like i'm not saying like oh
we americans need to like stop
vaccinating these freeloading canadians
but i think it's
shitty when people get to use like their
wealth by having a vacation home in
florida to basically cut ahead of other
people
uh and so that feels shitty even though
it's like yeah i mean you're over 65 and
like you're at risk and you should
you should be vaccinated uh but maybe
not exactly in this way yeah also case
numbers are way down in most provinces
of canada so like just stay there and
don't go to florida where things are
worse yeah
but there's i've heard on npr this week
yeah npr
coastal liberal elite um i heard that a
bunch of hollywood execs are flying
their private planes to florida to jump
ahead in vaccine lines because they
can't get them you can social distance
on a private plane but yeah
i usually no one should be going
anywhere right now i'm this is gonna
make me sound really authoritarian i
just think we should have shut down all
commercial travel except for like
certain purposes like just just take a
rest enjoy where you are walk places i
don't know
yeah it makes me so mad that people are
lying and stuff to get vaccinated
is [ __ ] people that are real bad are
going to get vaccinated long before
people that are good
people who have done whatever the [ __ ]
they wanted for the past year are going
to get it and some of us
who have been real good people are going
to be last in line
because as that green day song said i
think nice guys finish last which is a
very toxic logic
but well it feels shitty there's this
like there's people i know that are
[ __ ] idiots and being awful and like
in one way i'm gonna be super mad and
jealous that they're going to get
vaccinated before i do who's been like
taking things seriously at the other
side of things they are the ones who
need to be vaccinated because they're
the idiots spreading it you know
yeah that's a good point wow
but yeah i'd say to that that uh that
email none of us
like this okay um so we need to wrap up
soon there was an earthquake in serbie's
home that caused her
to fly towards her it dropped to my mic
i shouldn't joke because we're in
california and earthquakes are real
but it wasn't real earthquake um do we
have one more email we want to get
through real quick or should i
i think that's it uh thanks everyone can
i just say shout outs to the email i
forget the name right now it's not that
i had someone sent us a bunch of great
um reading
recommendations i really liked that yeah
they ended with the new george saunders
book which i'm very excited to read and
they
reminded me to grab a copy so thanks for
that and once again thank you to
everyone who writes in i think as i just
gave evidence that we gave evidence to
we read them all we like them all we
appreciate it so please once again write
us at culturebridgewisecrack.com
coltrangewisetrack.com
coltrangetrack.comm
and call us at
do that 213-534-8807-213-5348 tweet me
at siripatel22
yeah i'm also on the twitters it's it's
right on it's right on thing at
wisecrack alec
not very active on twitter so that
sounded very uncomfortable
nice michael o'burns trying to be less
active on twitter and uh you know sims
welcome
yeah also your account was shut down uh
for what 24 hours
he is a victim of 24 censorship on
inauguration day
a bunch of people i know all got their
accounts spent on inauguration day i
think it was some sort of like weird
all-right conspiracy
to make sure a bunch of weirdos couldn't
say weird stuff
or maybe it was like a far left i don't
maybe it was a corny conspiracy i don't
know
but we'll be back on culture binge in
two weeks
um thank you for being here set your
calendars we'll be back live then
catch you next time bye
[Music]
so